The West Wing was evacuated on Sunday
after a bag of white powder was
discovered in the White House the
evacuation was brief however after
officials remembered that Hunter Biden
doesn't snort Anthrax as far as We Know
the white powder turned out to be
nothing more than a first son favorite
booger sugar you know what I'm talking
about
some Colombian nose candy if you catch
my drift little Yale College baking soda
if you can infer my meaning I'm talking
about Coke
which means
that since the president's infamously
unrepentant dirt bag of a sun had been
visiting the White House that very
weekend A lot of people came to
conclusions about how the cocaine got
there MSNBC however
is shocked
and turning to some breaking news we
have just learned that a formal lab has
confirmed the suspicion that that white
powdery substance found in the west wing
on Sunday was in fact positive for
cocaine the discovery led to a brief
evacuation of the White House Sunday
night joining us now is NBC White House
correspondent Mike memley so Mike where
do things stand now this is so unusual
you and I have covered the White House
for years I can't even
fathom anything like this having been
found before In The West Wing and I go
back to the 70s at the White House so
this is pretty pretty wild
it's absolutely extraordinary Andrea and
this new conclusive test confirms what
had been the preliminary field test
conducted by DC fire Personnel who were
called in on Sunday night after the
discovery of this suspicious substance
by a uniformed officer in the Secret
Service that was conducting a routine
patrol of the White House and so to
recap on the developments from that
we've been reporting on yesterday this
was found we understand in a highly
trafficked common area of the West Wing
it's an area where individuals
especially visitors individuals who may
be coming for for instance a private
tour yeah we just but it's it's hard to
fathom
we just don't know
how on Earth cocaine made its way into
the Biden White House
who knows
who knows not to be outdone in
implausibility a law enforcement
official has gone on record to say that
the cocaine culprit is unlikely ever to
be found
because put the put the first son aside
for a second
because the culprit whoever he is in any
case is a friend of Joe Biden the only
people who make it into the West Wing
these days are friends and allies of Joe
Biden and the Democrats
and Democrat criminals generally
speaking with very few exceptions don't
face consequences because they don't get
charged because they don't get arrested
because they're usually not even
investigated right now go to cinch.com
use promo code Knowles a lot of family
gatherings lined up the last thing that
you need when hosting is turning on the
grill and finding out that you're out of
propane that is where our friends at
cinch come in cinch is a propane grill
tank Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane tanks right to your door on your
schedule and do not require any
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere I remember as a kid I used to
be kind of nervous when we go pick up
the propane tank and be in the car so
don't don't make any sudden moves so if
we don't get hit here I don't want to go
up in a ball in flame so I really like
the idea you just you just order it
pre-order it's super simple on your
phone just shows up at your door you
don't need to worry about it the perfect
summer night would not be complete
without cinch go online to cinch.com
where download the Cinch app to order
new customers get their first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks with promo
code Knolls cinch.com or download the
Cinch app use promo code nulls to get
your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks as a limited time offer you must
live with an essential service area to
redeem it go to cinch.com offer for
details right now go to geniusell.com
sold out of their Dark Spot Corrector
and our listeners have been begging for
a restock begging on their hands and
knees well I've got great news just in
time for the summer
it's back Jenny isl's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has not won but three Cutting
Edge ingredients and goes to work fast
to Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots and even old discoloration both on
your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
Jenny cell's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials such as
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed how quickly you will
see results or 100 of your money goes
back guaranteed go to genucel.com
Knowles right now
get your dark spot corrector in the
geniusell most popular package that is
geniusell.com Knowles right now save
over seventy seven zero percent off
Junior cell's most popular package all
orders will include a mystery luxury
gift while supplies last geniusell.com
Knowles great news that is not being
reported very much
about our political order this is such
great news it's not a sexy issue like a
beer company going woke or something so
people aren't talking but this is so
this is such a big win for conservatives
the northeast of America which has been
the dominant economic leader the
PowerHouse of America for I don't know
about as long as I can remember
is no longer the main driver of the
American economy
do you know which region is
the South
the liberal Northeast region
has lost its economic dominance
the conservative region the South has
taken it
why is that
because people are leaving the Northeast
because the Northeast has become
unlivable very difficult with stupid
regulations and stupid taxes and stupid
social policies especially the stupid
social policies
and they're moving to the South which is
not only Freer economically but perhaps
more importantly it's an it's still an
ordered Society
it's still a normal place where you can
live a normal life and I know all we
ever talk about is how well we've got
lower taxes here you know or hey we've
got fewer regulations so it's easier to
do business and that's true and those
were big motivating factors that got a
lot of us conservatives myself included
to leave liberal places and to move here
to Tennessee or Texas or Georgia or
Florida or these other places too but
more than that
it's the social stuff when people ask me
hey Michael how do you like Tennessee I
say I love Tennessee I said do you plan
to stay there I totally plan to stay
here why is that
I don't say because I have a little bit
more money which I do I do have a little
bit more money here because there's no
state income tax
what I always say is because I can raise
a family here because it's a nice normal
place to live because I love my
neighbors because there's a community
here because I love my Parish because I
because it's normal here and people
smile and are nice and talk about things
in a normal way
and it turns out that normality
and living in accordance with reality
is good for business too we can serve it
as we we fall for the same economics
exaltation that the leftists and even
that the marxists do the marxists
primary mistake was viewing man as
essentially an economic creature but man
is not essentially an economic Reacher
man is made in the image and likeness of
God and there's a lot more to life than
money so we want to go to economy but we
want that good economy in service of a
good society and a good life you don't
want to put the cart before the horse
and when you think about economics first
things are going to get out of whack you
see this not only on the left but even
on the right when conservatives try to
avoid the social issues and they just
wanted to talk about
occupational licensing reform or
whatever then we lost all of our power
and Society spun totally out of control
what we have learned I think in the last
10 years especially on the right is that
social issues are economic issues
there's you're not going to fix the
economic problem by having a social
truce or anything like that the social
issues do we respect life do we know
what marriage is do we support families
do we support growing families and
growing the Next Generation do we
recognize borders and the distinction
between a citizenry and foreign peoples
do we if we don't do that
then you can have all the economic
tinkering in the world it's not going to
fix your Society things are going to
continue to degrade
so now
Florida Georgia North Carolina South
Carolina my state of Tennessee and Texas
which is all my ex that's where All My
Exes Live they have economically
overtaken
Boston New York City Washington DC the
Northeast according to Bloomberg
the population in the Southeast grew by
2.2 million people in the last two years
it's the same consolation that we were
just talking about with Bud Light
bad systems can't go on forever
political orders always change and and
conservatives used to not like that last
part of it because we used to want to
believe hey look the America of
1958 that has to go on forever the uh
the America not even of 1778 not even of
1888 but of 19 mid 1950s America that is
the Eternal political order it has to go
on forever and any deviation from that
whatsoever is awful and terrible in a
violation of everything we hold dear and
we used to lament when the left would
tell us well that's not how politics
Works things change all the time we say
no we don't want it to change we want it
to remain exactly the same well yeah
it's
it's very sad to know that political
orders always have to change when things
are good but when things are bad and
decadent and corrupted as they are right
now then it's a great
consolation and hope to know that
political orders none of them not the
best one not the worst one none of them
go on forever
and also money talks and Bs walks and so
as the South as the conservative part of
the country gains more economic power
the south is going to be able to throw
its political weight around a little bit
more than we have in the past just as
the liberal Northeast was able to throw
its political weight around and dominate
the country for the last 100 years boy
what a great clip that was huh make sure
that you subscribe ring that Bell here
at the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time